einschulung in krisenzeiten für die
erstklässler in mecklenburg vorpommern
und die ministerpräsidentin manuela
schwesig beginnt ein besonderes
schuljahr nach corona bedingten
einschränkungen homeschooling und
sommerferien sind die kinder zurück in
der schule mecklenburg vorpommern wagt
seit vergangenem montag als erstes
bundesland die rückkehr zum
regelunterricht den normalen alltag
kommt auch wenn wir viele sachen
beachten müssen um das infektionsrisiko
zu verringern werden die schüler in
feste gruppen eingeteilt diese sollen
sich innerhalb der schule nicht begegnen
außerdem müssen schüler ab der fünften
klasse auf den fluren eine maske tragen
für die grundschüler gilt diese regel
nicht
[Musik]
weitere einschränkungen geben wird es
weitere lockerung geben
neben der politischen verantwortung für
ihr bundesland hat manuela schwesig auch
mit einer eigenen krise zu kämpfen
im vergangenen herbst macht sie ihre
krebserkrankung öffentlich während der
korona zeit steckt sie mitten in der
therapie auch die öffnung der schulen
betrifft die ministerpräsidentin privat
ihr sohn besucht die achte klasse
trotz der aktuell wieder steigenden
infektionszahlen in deutschland sieht
sie keinen grund von der öffnung der
schulen abzusehen
ich bin sowohl als mutter sowie als
ministerpräsidenten zuversichtlich dass
wir diesen schutz stadt gut vorbereitet
haben und bedanke mich bei allen die
sich da reingegangen
und ich habe noch nie so viele schüler
übrigens auch in den großen klassen
erlebt die sich auf diesen schulstadt
freuen denn wir haben alle in den
letzten wochen erlebt was es heißt wenn
schule nicht stattfindet
und ich freue mich sehr dass sie heute
bei mir sind manuela schwesig schönen
abend im vorjahr erholt gut gestärkt aus
dem urlaub zurück und natürlich gleich
ran an die arbeit in ihrem bundesland
mecklenburg vorpommern haben die schulen
als allererstes begonnen auch sie haben
eine masken pflicht eingeführt in ihrem
bundesland ab der fünften klasse aber
eben nicht wie in nordrhein westfalen
auch im unterricht warum nicht wir haben
uns entschieden hier moderat vorzugehen
es gibt ja mehrere sicherheitsstufen für
die schulen und die allererste ist
eigentlich gar nicht die ganzen
maßnahmen in der schule sondern kita und
schule sind am sichersten wenn außerhalb
von kita und schule die infektionszahlen
gering bleiben wir sind das bundesland
mit den geringsten infektionen von
anfang an bis heute
bayern hat acht mal mehr als wir zum
beispiel und deshalb ist die
voraussetzung für den schulstart zum
einen gut wir arbeiten mit freiwilligen
tests für lehrerinnen und lehrer aber
auch für nicht pädagogisches personal
wie hausmeister und sekretärin zum
beispiel und wir haben die klassen
getrennt also wir sagen wenn
klassenstufen zum beispiel auf dem
schulhof sind dann ist die fünfte
sechste die 78
die fünf und sechs so zusammen sieben
und acht sie sind getrennt auf den
schulhöfen und deshalb haben wir gesagt
da wo sie sich aber beginnen masten
pflicht und erst ab der fünften klasse
weil untersuchungen zeigen dass die
ansteckungsgefahr von chroma virus und
die weitergabe bei den kindern bis zehn
nicht so stark ist und deshalb haben wir
uns entschieden hier moderat ab klasse 5
eines ihrer kinder geht ja auch in die
schule und sie sind darüber reden wir
gleich noch risikopatientin haben sie
ein bisschen mulmiges gefühl
ich habe keine angst aber ich bin immer
dafür vorsichtig zu bleiben und ich bin
aber zuversichtlich dass es klappt weil
noch mal die infektionszahlen in
mecklenburg vorpommern sind von anfang
an wesentlich geringer als in anderen
bundesländern das gebe ich zu wenn ich
jetzt ministerpräsidentin von bayern
oder in
wie wäre da würde ich noch sorgenvoller
sein aber wir sind sehr vorsichtig
deshalb haben wir zum beispiel auch
diese woche entschieden dass es keine
weiteren lockerung qe weil der staat von
schule und kita geht vor ich finde jetzt
natürlich schüler dran die kinder die
familien und sie haben es angesprochen
mein sohn geht auf eine öffentliche
schule in der stadt schwerin
das ist eigentlich wie eine
großveranstaltung da sind 700
schülerinnen und schüler zusammen und
dort gelten aber genau diese regeln und
ich habe einen riesenrespekt muss ich
wirklich sagen vor den lehrerinnen und
lehrern die haben uns alles abgetrennt
die klassen und er ist jetzt die letzte
erst vorerst fröhlich hin gegangen
obwohl er auch zu den größeren schülern
gehört der die sich um eine woche mehr
ferien gefolterten und er kam zurück und
hat gesagt es läuft im herbst 2009 10
und auch davor haben viele dann respekt
auch ihm gegenüber gezeigt haben sie
ihre brustkrebserkrankung öffentlich
gemacht im juni diesen jahres war klar
sie haben es überstanden haben sie auf
die pandemie auf maßnahmen
einschränkungen anders geguckt hat ihre
eigene erkrankung sie in irgendeiner art
und weise beeinflusst dabei ich hätte
alle entscheidungen genauso getroffen
auch ohne die krebserkrankung für mich
war von anfang an klar
eine solche pandemie die ja nicht
irgendwie langsam sich steigert sondern
richtig heftig kommt muss man da muss
man sofort drauf hauen und wir hatten
ein bisschen den vorteil dass wir im
norden noch 14 tage voller fahrten und
wir haben sofort reagiert also dass wir
das abgeschnitten haben und ich bin
gehören generell zu denen die klar und
klare und konsequente linie verfolgen
aber ich konnte mich gut reinversetzen
in die vielen tausenden menschen die
schon schwer erkrankt sind und ganz
ehrlich wenn man gegen eine schwere
erkrankung kämpft hat man nicht
interesse nach kona virus zu halten wir
auch verständnis für all diejenigen die
bis heute sehr wütend frustriert und
auch man muss es sagen traurig sind weil
sie zum einen vielleicht nicht zu ihren
angehörigen konnten im pflegeheim weil
wirklich wichtige operation auch fair
und aufgeschoben sind konnten sie das
nachvollziehen
total wie wenn er oft gefragt was war
die schwerste entscheidung
und für mich war definitiv die schwerste
entscheidung die besuchsrechte in
pflegeheimen und krankenhäusern
einzuschränken
ich bin selber kurz bevor es losgegangen
ist aus dem krankenhaus gekommen und
hatte zum glück meine tumor op hinter
mir und habe in dieser zeit erlebt was
das bedeutet wie wichtig es ist in
solchen dunkle moment muss die familie
da ist und zu sagen ihr könnt ja jetzt
nicht hin ist ein ganz ganz schwerer
einschränkungen ich bin froh dass wir
hier wieder geöffnet haben aber ich will
es auch deshalb deutlich sagen weil ja
viel auch diskutiert wird wir haben es
ja eben gesehen auch zum beispiel gegen
die masten pflicht ich will ganz
deutlich sagen es gibt wesentlich mehr
menschen die viel härteres durchmachen
das sind zum beispiel die älteren die
kranken die nicht so viel besucher haben
konnten wie sie es eigentlich bräuchten
die diagnose frau schwesig war er
sicherlich ein schock
sie sind eine junge frau kennen es
selber von zwei freundinnen die das in
einem ähnlichen alter auch erlebt haben
und man muss sich erstmal sortieren wie
geht man mit der familie um was macht
man mit den mit den kindern und vieles
vieles mehr und sie sind vor die presse
getreten und haben das öffentlich
gemacht warum also dahinter steckte
wahrscheinlich keine erwartungen war das
für sie so eine art reinigung oder wie
muss man sich das vorstellen
ich habe ja ein öffentliches amt ich bin
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern und ich bin immer sehr dafür
dass die menschen wissen woran sie sind
und es war ja auch klar dass man eine
solche erkrankung nicht einfach mit
links und 40 fieber nacht sondern dass
ich vielleicht bestimmte termine nicht
wahrnehmen kann weil ich zur therapie
muss und ich bin generell jemand der
immer sehr offen die karten auf den
tisch legt und es war mir einfach
wichtig offen damit umzugehen und ich
war extrem positiv überrascht über die
hohe anteilnahme und das hat mir auch
wahnsinnig viel rückhalt gegeben und
dieser hat sein dass bürgerinnen und
bürger geschrieben haben mir glück
steine geschickt haben und ein
blumenmeer
und ich kann mich noch gut erinnern
in diesem tag denke ich oft dran weil es
fast ein jahr her ist als ich die
diagnose bekommen habe es ist ein
wahnsinnig schwerer schock für sie für
ein selbst und die familie aber wenn man
dann mit ärzten spricht mit therapeuten
was ist möglich dann gibt es viele
möglichkeiten es gibt keine garantie
dass es gut geht aber es gibt die chance
und das will ich heute abend sagen
für diejenigen die vielleicht gerade in
diesen tagen auch eine solche diagnose
bekommen haben es lohnt sich zu kämpfen
und sie haben gekämpft und sie hatten
großen rückhalt durch in man auch durch
ihre kinder wie wie sind sie im laufe
des prozesses mit ihren kindern vor
allen dingen umgegangen also ich habe
mit meinen freundinnen jetzt gerade
schon erzählt aber auch dann wie reden
wir mit ihm kann man denen das zoom und
man kann kindern sehr viel zumuten weil
sie so unbedacht sind trage ich eine
perücke trage ich keine perücke
sie haben sich zum beispiel für eine
perücke entschieden für sich selbst oder
für die kinder oder also diese frage wie
sag ich's den kindern war die frage
nämlich auch am meisten umgetrieben hat
auch meinen mann und natürlich haben wir
nächtelang auf dem sofa gesessen und
überlegt wie machen wird ist eigentlich
alles und ich bin total positiv auch
überrascht gewesen wie kinder es
annehmen und auch doch wegsteckt man hat
der wahnsinnige angst vor mein sohn ist
ja jetzt 13 der versteht natürlich was
eine krebsdiagnose bedeutet für ihn war
wichtig dass ich den satz mein mann hat
krebs gleich ergänze mit dem satz aber
ich werde wieder gesund ich war da von
anfang an zuversichtlich obwohl ich
wusste dass es keine garantie gibt und
dass er gesehen hat dass ich auch
regelmäßig zu den therapien gehe mir
mehr zeit dafür nehmen
das hat ihn schon glaube ich auch dann
beruhigt meine tochter ist vier das
haben wir einfach erklärt man mama hat
auch an der brust und geht jetzt immer
zum arzt und oft kam die hausärztin auch
zu mir wenn sie etwas begleitet hat in
der therapie und ja da war meine tochter
feuer und flamme wenn die ärzten kam war
alles toll und sie will jetzt selber
ärztin werden also die kinder es ist
wirklich so sie speichern des handy mehr
spritzen der infocomm und wurde besser
der teddy parallel behandelt aus dem
kinderarzt koffer und er hat es schwerer
als ich definitiv
aber ich auch da möchte ich mut machen
ich glaube es ist jeder muss selbst
seinen weg finden das ist klar andere
sagen nee ich ziemlich zurück aber diese
offene umgang und die ehrlichkeit
gegenüber den kindern ist wichtig und
hilft haben sie denn den tag als sie
dann erfahren haben sie haben es
überwunden sie haben es überstand haben
sie den gefeiert oder war das eher ein
ruhiger moment für sie also man stellt
sich das ja so vorher nicht wenn nicht
das alles hinter mir habe dann gibt es
eine große fete die hätte es jetzt nicht
geben können
aber es war ganz anders ich bin zur
abschlussuntersuchung gefahren und nach
hause gekommen und es war ein warmer
schon so ein vor sommerlicher tag und da
saßen wir abends im garten und haben
einfach gegrillt und saßen ganz still
und ruhig zusammen und waren total
glücklich und oft habe ich wenn es
schwierig war eine therapie auch mal die
augen zugemacht und herren sommer ist
alles vorbei dann bist du mit der
familie im urlaub und hat sich jetzt auf
hiddensee einer ostsee war da war echt
so ein moment am meer wo ich dachte wow
jetzt ist es so die frage ist ja auch in
der in der politik geht es vor allen
dingen auch um macht um stärke jetzt
haben sie sich eben auch vor die presse
gestellt sie sind offen damit umgegangen
wie viel schwächer auch gerade als frau
darf man sich denn eigentlich leisten
man darf sich gar keine schwäche in der
politik leisten ich glaube nicht dass
man mir ja fehlentscheidungen oder
schlechte politik verziehen hätte nur
weil ich gerade einen krebs erkrankt bin
habe ich mir überhaupt gar keine
illusionen gemacht und deswegen war es
für mich anfangen von anfang an wichtig
dass ich auch die arbeit gut mache also
dass ich das auch packe zwischendurch
mal im moment gehabt wo sie gesagt haben
ich vielleicht shop pack ist doch nicht
ich habe mir das vorher gut überlegt ich
weiß ja was so ein amt bedeutet habe
dass deswegen war ich auch sehr offen
habe das eben offen mit meinem team
besprochen mit der landesregierung und
den ministerinnen und ministern und habe
ganz wie haben ganz klar miteinander
besprochen wann bin ich in der therapie
waren vertreten sie mich bitte und es
hat geklappt ich hatte wirklich
unterstützung dafür bin ich auch sehr
dankbar
und ja zum schluss kamen kroner dazu das
war heftig und
ich bin sehr froh dass es trotz dieser
erkrankung gelungen ist das land doch
durch diese krone krise bisher gut zu
steuern hat sie die krankheit in
irgendeiner weise verändert sagen sie
als auch bei ein paar sachen mensch
kommt lasst mal fünfe gerade sein freuen
sich darüber aufgeregt oder so sind sie
ruhig ist kann man das überhaupt schon
sagen keine ahnung
ja ich hatte ehrlich gesagt noch gar
nicht so viel zeit darüber nachzudenken
weil wir direkt in der bekämpfung der
krone krise sind aber natürlich ist es
so dass man das leben viel mehr
wertschätzt und so ganz einfache momente
sind für mich total wichtig also mit der
familie frühstücken und wir hatten jetzt
zwanzigster hochzeitstag und da freut
man sich einfach dass das aber
hoffentlich weiter so bleibt die
sinnfrage warum mache ich das ist alles
auch das mit der politik ich mache jetzt
vielleicht mal was sie wollten
eigentlich erzieherin werden zum
beispiel also ja das ist eine spannende
frage und ein bekannter hat mir mal
gesagt ja mal wenn du da durch bist dann
musst du musst dir was tolles vornehmen
einen berg besteigen ohne rad ruhig sagt
nein ich will eigentlich nur mein leben
so wie es ist fortführen dürfen
ich habe eine tolle familie ich habe
einen aufreibenden aber wirklich einen
super job ich meine 30 jahre deutsche
einheit im freien land ich bin ein kind
der wende dass sich ein land regieren
darf das ist ein wirklich war für mich
etwas besonderes auch in diesen schweren
zeiten
was macht so etwas mit einem ass macht
einen stark und demütig zugleich
man hat gesehen dass man zusammen mit
unterstützung auch so etwas bekämpfen
kann es hat mich einerseits gestärkt
aber es hat mich auch sehr demütig
gemacht dass man dankbar für gesundheit
sein sollte und auch für das leben was
ich habe und ich danke ihnen sehr dass
sie gekommen sind und auch vor allen
dingen für ihre offenheit und auch für
das vertrauen und wünschte ihnen zum
schluss sie haben es gerade selber
gesagt das was wir alle immer einfach so
für selbstverständlich nehmen unsere
gesundheit und ich wünsche ihnen viel
gesundheit für die nächsten 194.000
jahre manuela schwesig vielen dank für
ihren besuch
das wünsche ich ihnen auch danke sehr